hi
my name is david weiner i'm a product
manager at google
focus on the kotlin language compiler
and libraries
hi i'm james ward a developer advocate
at google cloud and i've been doing a
lot of kotlin lately
and we're here to talk today about what
kotlin is
and why it's a great language for cloud
so let's get started first we want to
give an overview of what kotlin looks
like
and what some of its features are
kotlin is a jvm language so it looks a
lot like
java in some ways and uses a lot of the
same machinery under the hood there are
some cool kind of differentiating
features though
the first is that nullability is baked
into the type system in kotlin
so this question mark operator that you
see here actually makes it so the
compiler and tooling
caches a lot of the potential mall
pointer exceptions you might be used to
seeing at runtime
kotlin also has first class support for
lambdas through this nice trailing
lambda syntax
and functional programming is a really
core part of kotlin as a language
kotlin also has this template expression
syntax
that make it so you don't have to kind
of mess with string concatenation as
much
and this is a small one but semicolons
are optional so one less thing to think
about when you're programming
there are a lot more larger features
that are kind of core to what kotlin is
as a language
kotlin has co-routines which are these
great primitives for
writing reading and reasoning about
concurrent code
it's also 100 interoperable java so you
don't have to migrate your whole project
over
in order to start using kotlin you can
start with just one class or
one file kotlin is also expressive and
concise
we routinely hear from teams how nice it
is to start writing in kotlin
because you can say more with less code
and last but not least kotlin's lan uh
trailing lambus syntax
which uh you kind of just saw an example
of lets you create domain-specific
languages or dsls
really easily this lets you do things in
a concise way that you wouldn't expect
from a type safe jvm language like
generating markup
configuring your build or really
concisely configuring routes for a web
server
so we've talked about what kotlin is and
now
wanted to dive into the history of
kotlin and why teams are
adopting it
the kotlin project was originally
created 10 years ago
but it really started accelerating in
2016.
that's when 1.0 was released and android
announced official support for it
in 2017. it grew really quickly on
android
which is one of the largest java
language platforms in the world
and by 2019 more than 50 of the top
thousand apps on the play store
were using kotlin and this year kotlin
pulled ahead to become the number two
language on the jvm ahead of scala it's
routinely reported as the number one
fastest growing language in the world
and we'll look at a couple of concrete
examples of that
so here's just a sampling of companies
that are using kotlin
in production today and you'll notice
that many of them are mobile first
companies
a lot of them started using kotlin on
android but many are growing
it on the server side as well the main
takeaway here is that kotlin
has had a lot of time to incubate and
grow through usage in some of these
flagship companies
it's production ready and at google
we're also going all in on kotlin it's
our
preferred language for android app
development now and here's an example of
just some of the results
the google home app team saw when moving
100 of their new feature development to
kotlin
they saw a 33 reduction in the
null pointer exceptions they saw from
their app um
and when they moved classes from java to
kotlin
uh they saw on average a 30 reduction in
the lines of code
additionally we're also seeing a lot of
teams internally within google
adopt kotlin on the server side uh now
so metrics teams a number of our logging
teams
uh platform teams for a number of our
largest products have just started
introducing kotlin
and the internal server framework that
powers google applications
is migrating to kotlin as well lastly i
wanted to bring
the concision point to life this is one
of the reasons that
people seem to enjoy programming in
kotlin the most
so what you see here is a plain old java
object that you might notice
has a lot of boilerplate code person
java
so it has getters setters and equals
method
hashcode and a lot more it might look
familiar to you
now here's the exact same object in
kotlin
and you might be wondering what happened
to all the extra code
kotlin language features take care of
generating the necessary byte code for
you
so there's getters setters hashcode are
still there
only you don't have to worry about
handwriting them
instead you can spend time being
creative implementing new features that
your customers actually need
and not worrying about writing hundreds
of lines of boilerplate
so now i'll hand things over to james to
talk about how kotlin can work
with some of the server tools frameworks
and apis
that you might already be using
so kotlin works great on the server and
on the cloud it works great on google
cloud
so if you're using just raw compute
instances or you're using
kubernetes or cloud run or any of the
other compute platforms
kotlin is awesome because it runs on the
jvm it interoperates with
java and a lot of the modern java based
frameworks are now supporting kotlin as
well so for example
spring boot has added great kotlin
support there's a
new framework called micronaut that also
has great kotlin support
there's support now in kotlin for grpc
and then there's a really new project
called cloud state and so we'll go over
some of these
but let's start with spring boot spring
boot
is the most popular enterprise framework
and
usually people are using that with java
but now with the new kotlin support
you can use kotlin with spring boot and
it feels really natural you still get
the annotation based injection
and all the other great parts of spring
boot but then you as well as that
get all the features of kotlin including
co-routines and null safety and all that
great stuff
so let's actually take a look at a demo
let's look at some code
and deploy a spring boot kotlin
application on the cloud
let's take a look at a little demo of a
spring boot kotlin application and run
it in the cloud
i'm on a repo here on github james ward
and then spring boot kotlin
reactive demo and before we take a look
at the code let's go get this thing
deploying up on the cloud
one way to do that is to hit this run on
google cloud button
so i'll hit that and now it's going to
say are you sure i'm going to confirm
and it's now launching cloud shell cloud
shell
is a vm in the cloud with a ssh
like web interface to it and this just
allows us to automate a few steps so we
don't have to do much typing
so let's clone that git repo we're just
looking at and then it's asking me which
project i want to use i will use jw demo
it's going to enable cloud run on that
project and then it's going to ask me
which region
i want to use i'll use us central one
and
now it will go through some steps to
deploy this application from that source
code
up onto google cloud so we'll check back
in on this in a second because it's
going to take
a minute or so to do that while it's
doing that
we can take a look at a little bit of
stuff in this project first there's the
palm xml this should be familiar this is
for the maven build
nothing too exciting in here other than
the kotlin stuff
spring boot stuff and you'll see that
i'm using webflux so that we get a
non-blocking reactive
http server for the spring boot project
so nothing caught on yet but let's go
take a look at the kotlin source code
this is in the demo
application and really basic spring boot
application here
so i've got my my demo application class
which has my router in it and we'll take
a look at that method
in a second i'm using some kotlin
features here like a data class called
release
and then i have a function main that
starts up my demo application
so what this application does very
simple it's going to make an http
request out to the github
api to fetch the tags for
kotlin releases and this is using the
web client which is also
a non-blocking webflux-based http client
so because of kotlin co-routines and a
great feature of kotlin
we have a suspend function so even
though this is a non-blocking
async call we're able to make it look
like it's just a sequential
so we're going to get our releases which
are going to deserialize into our list
of release
and what i was trying to do with this
application is just get the actual
releases not any milestone releases so
we see some other features of kotlin
here
one is that uh the the question mark or
the elvis operator
used for dealing with null ability
because maybe my releases were null i
didn't
have any releases or i wasn't able to
fetch the releases
then i can do that question mark so
chain on operations when it's not null
so then i can do a filter
with a nice little function syntax there
to filter out anything that doesn't uh
contain a dash dasher that does filter
out all the things that contain a dash
and then i'm going to again use the nice
nullability support in kotlin get the
first or null
and if it's not null then i'm going to
get the name of that release
and then if any of those operations in
that chain
were null then i'm going to provide a
default of not found
so some really nice features of kotlin
here
in a spring boot application let's check
back
back in on cloud shell and see how we're
doing so it looks like it's all up and
running
so i did the maven package jib build
jib is a nice maven or gradle plug-in
that can create
container images docker container images
and so
it did that for us created our docker
container image and stored it up on the
google container registry
and then once we get our container image
for our application
up on the google container registry we
can do our
gcloud run deploy and deploy this
application from that container image so
with some parameters there
but our application was deployed and now
it's up and running so let's go check it
out
here on the cloud and make sure that we
see the latest kotlin
release here so it's now starting up
that application making that
non-blocking request out to the github
api getting back that list getting the
first one
after applying the filter and there is
our latest release of kotlin so there's
our really basic
spring boot kotlin application running
up on google cloud
using cloud run which is serverless and
i'll show you just real quickly
some of the features of cloud run we can
click through into the ui for cloud run
where we can also do deployments and
create new revisions and check the logs
and see metrics and all that kind of
stuff
so here we have our application up and
running where we can come in and check
out the revisions
we can see that there was one that was
deployed two minutes ago
and then check out the logs for the
application see it all up and running
and see details and deploy new revisions
and do
great things so nice thing about cloud
run is it's serverless so that means
there's no servers to maintain and it
scales up and down
based on our demand so that is our
spring boot
cut line application running up on
google cloud
okay so that was an example of using
spring boot and kotlin
on the cloud but now let's talk about
grpc
grpc allows us to use protocol buffers
to define
our data objects so we have a language
agnostic way
to define something like a greeter
service and then the messages that that
service can handle
so this allows us to use grpc with any
language
it's protocol agnostic supports strong
typing
it'll generate the the objects around
those uh those services and messages
and then it'll also generate the clients
and service objects to
interact with those services from a
client to a server
and best of all it's super fast because
it's built on http 2.
so we now support kotlin with grpc
through a project called grpc kotlin
so in grpc kotlin what we do is we
generate kotlin idiomatic stubs
based on the java stubs that are
generated by the java grpc project
so this supports co-routines for doing
async stuff it supports the
kotlin flow api for doing stream based
processing
so that means that your services can
take a stream as an input
and or return a stream as an output and
then you use the standard flow api to
interact with it
there's plugins for doing grpc kotlin
for both gradle and maven
and of course it's available in maven
central so easy to get
so let's take a look at a demo for grpc
kotlin
and it's stream support and running on
the cloud with cloud run
now let's take a look at an example that
uses grpc
and kotlin you can find this on github
under the google cloud platform kotlin
samples and then run
and then grpc hello world streaming
there's a few different examples in here
we're going to look at the streaming one
and if you want to deploy this up on
cloud run
you can just click this run on google
cloud button and
that will deploy it and we'll let
cloud shell start up and then go take a
look at the
source code so in the source code for
this
sample let's first take a look at the
protofile this
is the protocol buffer definition that
defines a service called greeter
an rpc on that service called say hello
stream
it takes a hello request and it returns
a stream
of hello reply and then you can see our
hello request and hello reply
message objects down below so
the grpc kotlin project will then
generate
the classes to interact with the service
for
kotlin and let's go take a look at how
we actually use those generated stubs
here we have the hello world server and
we'll start up the server
and the the all that the server does is
implement
what happens on that say hello stream
so you can see it takes a hello request
and it returns a flow
of hello reply because our grpc
returned that stream of hello reply flow
in kotlin
is a way to do to do a stream
uh with non-blocking uh back pressure
and all that kind of good stuff
so we're going to omit a hello reply
and what we're going to do in that reply
is create
a new hello reply from the builder and
set the message to hello and then
whatever name came in the request
so we're just going to emit that every
second so that's our server
implementation
nothing very fancy there then let's go
take a look at the client
that uses connects to that server so in
this case we're going to use the
generated stubs for this grpc service
and we're going to to have a function in
here
called greet which is going to take a
name and then it's going to
do this run blocking where it's going to
assemble
a hello request and set the name to
whatever is passed in
and then it's going to call the stub say
hello stream
give it that request and this returns a
flow
so that's the the kotlin flow and then
we're going to do a dot collect on here
with
a function that takes the response and
in this case
we're just going to print out the
message that was passed in
now down here we can see our main method
where we start
up the client and you'll see that when
we start up the client we're going to
if there is an argument we're going to
use it an argument to the program if not
we're going to just
pass in world so you'll see that what
actually then gets passed in
we set the name to the name that was
there and if we look back at our server
it sets the message that it's going to
emit every second to hello comma
and then the name that was passed in so
let's go
back over into cloud shell and i'm
actually just going to cancel out of
this where i'm not going to go through
the deployment
because we don't need to it's already
deployed and now i'm going to run the
client against
my server that's up and running on cloud
run
so what i'm doing is i'm taking the
docker container that was created
if we had followed through with that
process and let it run to create the
docker container from that source code
but i've already done that and then it's
going to
run the hello world client kt
application
and then it's going to pass an argument
to the application which is the server
to connect to
and if you'll remember we take that
argument and we output it after hello
every second so let's now run that
docker container it's going to go grab
that from the google container registry
and download that to cloud shell to my
local docker daemon there
and so that'll take a second to pull
that down
and once that's pulled down it'll start
up the
docker container run the hello world
client and
then connect to our service running on
cloud run
and remember cloud run is serverless so
it scales down when there aren't any
requests and then automatically scales
back
up as needed and you'll see that it's
started up that grpc server
and now it's outputting every second
hello with that argument that was passed
in
so there we go that's our kotlin grpc
application
running on cloud run and doing a
streaming response
so that was grpc kotlin now let's take a
look at a new project called cloud state
which has great kotlin support as well
cloud state was created to support
distributed programming
through some new architectural patterns
called event sourcing
cqrs and crdts and i'm not going to go
into all the details of what those are
but if you want to do really high scale
distributed
computing then you may need
architectural patterns that support that
so the new cloud state project is open
source and has a cloud service built on
google cloud
that we can use with kotlin to build
these massive scale
applications let's take a look at a
little demo of cloud state with kotlin
let's take a look at a cloud state
kotlin example that uses the light bend
cloud state service to run this on the
cloud
and you can find the source code on
github
james ward cloud state sample fraud
okay first let's take a look at the code
so with cloud state we use
protobufs to model the messages that
we're going to send
and then the rpc operations that will be
performed
so we have a transaction with a
timestamp amount location and just
description and then we have a user
transaction
that associates that with a cloud state
entity key which allows us to do the
partitioning of the messages
and that also gives us the ability to
scale this thing
up and down horizontally based on what's
happening the messages as they're being
partitioned
okay and then we have a way to add the
transaction a user transaction
and get transactions let's take a look
at the
activity entity and this is where the
logic for
handling those messages happens so we've
got an event sourced entity
and then you can see there's a
constructor argument with the user id
which is our partitioning key so that's
how we're able to partition this data
in this class we have our transactions
which is our mutable list
and so whenever we get transaction
messages coming in
then we're going to be able to add them
to this list so that we have our
accumulated state here in this entity
then we have a command handler for add
transaction which takes that user
transaction
and then we also get a context command
context with there
and then we can have our logic for
detecting fraud on a transaction
so whenever a new transaction comes in
we're going to use the past data and the
new
transaction to calculate the
velocity and so there's obviously lots
of different ways that we would
calculate
compute whether or not the transaction
is potentially fraudulent
for this simple example i'm just using
velocity
and if the user's velocity goes over a
max velocity
then we're going to say that there's
possible fraud and
in this case we're just going to output
to that to the console
but then once we have potentially
detected the potential fraud
we are going to emit a message which
says okay we've done our handling of
this message and then that event handler
will trigger
this will go on to an event log which is
persisted
in spanner in google cloud's banner
okay so that's the the bulk of the
entity processing
i've got a little class that just starts
up the server and then i've got a
simulator class that is going to
simulate some transactions so let's go
over and run this now
i already have this up and running on
google cloud via the light pen cloud
state service but let's go start up the
simulator
and what this will do is start adding a
bunch of transactions to this
transaction log
and what we'll be able to do once it
starts emitting those messages will be
able to see the messages that are being
emitted
here in the console and then we'll go
over to google cloud logging
to actually see if we get a potential
fraud so here we go that we're now
feeding a bunch of transactions into
that system the we've got multiple
users so we're doing partitioning of the
data for that entity
and now here in cloud the log loop
viewer in google cloud
now we can see the server messages from
my entity that's running up on
google cloud and lightbend cloud state
so let's go try to jump to now and see
there we go okay
so it looks like we just got a possible
fraud alert and we can see the user id
the merchant
the amount when it happened and then the
google map link to where that
transaction was
and if we let this continue running we
probably will see
some more potential fraud alerts coming
in
as that simulator runs so you can see
we're feeding in tons of messages
they're partitioned based on user id so
we get the ability to auto scale this
service
up and down and that's that's great for
something like this where the amount of
transactions that are coming in is going
to fluctuate
throughout the day with probably more
transactions happening
in the morning and evening i would guess
and less at night
and so so great we can scale our service
automatically
based on that there's a container image
that i built
and deployed which contains my
entity code okay so that's the quick
example
of cloud state running on the light been
cloud state
service so that was cloud state for
kotlin
and that's it that we wanted to show you
today uh thanks for watching
and we hope that you will build kotlin
stuff for google cloud and check out
some resources for that
you can go to cloud.google.com kotlin
and thanks so much david for joining us
and showing us why we should use kotlin
yeah thanks james we're really excited
to see what you build with kotlin
and hope you enjoy the rest of next on
air